i i love cooking um i i often say to
people
to sort of give some perspective on what
i feel like i'm good at like
i leave out racing because that's what i
used to do and i say if there's two
things i'm good at
i could say driving but instead i say
cooking and working out
i'm pretty good at those two things um
and so
i make really simple food but i always
tell people
i because it always tastes really good
i'm like
i think the difference is i love it like
i love making it i love
the food and i don't and i am i don't
even like to throw it away i'm like a
hoarding queen when it comes to poo
cause i'm like nah nah
i put love and care and energy into that
food and like i care about that food and
it's really high quality and there's no
point in throwing that out
and so it's i do believe in that
and so i i mean i think that what it
what is like a technique that someone
could do
to start like initiating this practice
maybe like
maybe give us a technique for uh
activating or
checking in with our chakras our seven
chakras
and then perhaps putting energy into
food and some simple things that people
can do at home that are very simple
oh i love it okay so this is this is the
easiest thing
and it's almost gonna sound like it's
too simple but this is what i teach
people
and so most people most of us have some
sort of a gratitude practice
right and and if you don't have one
that's okay i would i would um
you know i would recommend trying one
out so let's say you start off your day
before you get out of bed or maybe
you're journaling and you're writing
down or thinking and connecting with the
things that you love that you're
grateful for
when you're in that process and if
you're thinking about your kids or your
or your fur babies you know
or something that you love to eat like
your favorite dish you're gonna make
tonight because your best friend is in
town whatever it is
when you're connecting to that i want
you to connect to it
until you feel like almost like a
visceral response like you
feel like a physical response to it
right
and then that's when you're making that
connection that emotional energetic
connection to your physical body that's
something that's easy for your body to
remember
so you know if you're loving it you if
you think about the person you love you
literally start to tingle
right you feel warm if you're thinking
about that favorite food that your mom
used to make
um you can smell it you can smell it you
can taste it you might even like
salivate a little bit
and have all these memories this is so
important then you take this
energy and when you go to your kitchen
whether or not you're just doing your
lemon water
at the start of the day or you're making
a smoothie or coffee whatever it is
i want you to now take that feeling that
you
it's like tangible because you just
connected to it this really
and then you're going to intentionally
direct that energy towards that which
you're now going to put back into your
body
or that you're going to serve to someone
else let's say you're making breakfast
you're prepping food
it sounds so simple that it's almost
like
that can't possibly it works it's so
simple and you're just redirecting that
energy making that connection it's
almost like
it's almost like when you when you talk
to plants
you know we have there's so many studies
and there's that japanese doctor with
the water
and it's that thought it's powerful it's
not tangible but it is
you know and so now you're putting that
energy back into
like a food beverage something that
you're now going to put back into your
physical body
there's lots of studies on that there's
lots of studies the water study
there's the great plant study you'd
speak highly to one plant you hate the
other plants
there's like the rice experiment where
they divided like cooked rice into three
jars
and spoke differently to each jar and
they completely
manifested different mold profiles and
colors
um this is like absolutely a hundred
percent you can anybody can google these
tests but um what's the doctor's a moda
mossam what's his name
is i think it's um umoto or it's just
an m yeah it's like moto or moto massa
morimoto something like that
look up like water study and you'll
absolutely see
like water being spoken has different
intentions to it and it shows
um under a microscope yeah the molecules
the molecules
of the water look completely different
so for people listening if they don't
feel like
this is in any way uh
tangible real visual like there are
actual visual studies of
energy into
somewhat live but inanimate objects yeah
they can
you know literally leads to a completely
different conclusion with them so why
would it be different with your food
when you say put the energy into your
food
that still is a little bit of a
confusing directive
so maybe go through the process of how
exactly you do it
so so now you've connected right with
that feeling from
doing your gratitude you know your
gratitude practice gratitude list you
can
feel how it feels when you're super
grateful about something you love it so
much right
you're gonna go downstairs to your
kitchen or maybe you don't have stairs
you're gonna go into your kitchen
and now you're preparing whatever it is
that you're making something to drink a
water
tea you're making your food when you're
when i say put that energy back into
your beverage or your food
you're doing it with gratitude so you
can literally say
i'm so grateful for this lemon water
because i know it's going to heal and
nourish me
i'm so grateful for this amazing spread
you know of
of food from the farmers market i'm so
grateful i
have a chance to make breakfast for the
person that i love today or
god i love coffee so much thank god for
this cup of coffee
i mean whatever it is that you're doing
it's just taking that moment but
and it could be you're saying thank
thank you it's honestly the easiest
thing to
to do there's a few words that are so
powerful
as we know i am so powerful and thank
you
so powerful so just being able to say
that to
to your food or your beverage as you're
putting it back in or
if you're just prepping that's another
way just to acknowledge
that which is in front of you and in a
way you're just you're honoring that
you're honoring those
carrots and potatoes that you're
preparing for dinner
just putting that energy back in that
way you're
literally sending that energy back into
the food
which changes the resonance you know
of the food which elevates it and then
that goes back into your body and
actually
environmentally you're also elevating
you know the resonance
the frequency around you as well so
so that is something i hope it's like a
little bit more tangible because now you
can have words and thoughts that are
connected to just like the feeling
that you're directing and putting it
back in so an
easy way to uh to make a reference to it
if it's if it's a little hard
for someone to kind of conceptualize
that is think about someone that you
love
it's what you just did in bed before you
got out of bed is you're going to just
think about how that feels and think
about gosh if that person were having a
bad day
like and i just want to like i wish i
could hug them but i'm not there right
now and you're thinking about them and
that love and concern
that you're sending to them because you
want them to feel you as much as you
they possibly can
even though you're not there that's what
you're doing
but you're doing it with food